it is great to be joined today by
Congressman ROA Khanna who represents
California's 17th congressional district
located in Silicon Valley in the Bay
Area among his many characteristics is
notable that he takes no corporate PAC
money we'll also talk about some of his
progressive stances congressman thank
you so much for being here today David
thank you for having me on so to begin
with let's talk about this issue of not
taking corporate PAC money I've seen
this as a potentially really important
sort of incremental move in the
direction of getting money out of
politics and it can be very hard when we
talk about that because it's such a big
issue to imagine the end point where we
ultimately want to be but it seems that
that's something that every candidate
and elected official can choose to do
right now in other words they don't need
a constitutional amendment to do that
they don't need to change the law they
can just say this is something I can do
do you see it as a sort of logical
incremental step in that direction I do
when I got to Congress I formed the
Notepad caucus along with beta or Roark
and I know when we did that it was very
controversial there were only seven of
us who didn't take PAC money out of 435
members of Congress and even some of
those seven who didn't take that but he
do want to be affiliated with the no PAC
caucus for fear of offending their
colleagues one I think you've seen the
success of Beto's campaign in Texas to
show that not taking PAC money is
actually a politically savvy move and
Connor Lamb who doesn't share my
politics is much more moderate he ran on
not taking PAC money in a moderate
district Alexandria Ocasio Cortes ran on
it in a liberal district I think it's
something that cuts across ideology and
it's something that signals to voters
that you want to change the system now
we need to go much beyond not taking PAC
money because the reality is I still
take contributions as do most people
from individuals were wealthy there are
a lot of contributions that come from
the max $2,700 and that gives a
disproportionate voice not to
single individual but to a given set
class of individuals only 5% or so
Americans contribute to political
campaigns so I propose with Russ
Feingold as build democracy dollars to
give every American citizen $50 to
contribute to campaigns I think that's
the kind of radical transformation that
we need for a democracy but no tax is a
important first step
yeah I was with Bakari sellers over the
weekend in Los Angeles at politican and
he uses this term unilateral disarmament
when it comes to a lot of political
issues but but also the issue of
accepting money and to some degree
you're you're not going to win if you
just say I'm going to give up every
element of how politics are financed so
to a certain degree you sort of need to
make that calculation but in thinking
about that what would be the next step
like after no corporate PAC money what
do you see as the next intermediate step
in the direction that that we ultimately
want to go I think looking at what
Bernie Sanders accomplished at a
presidential level of a bado
accomplished at a senatorial level and
then is expanding small dollar
contributions and Alexandria did this to
some extent in her congressional
campaign the challenge is how do you
expand your small dollar donors on
social media through organizing and how
do you do that if you're not a celebrity
right I mean Bernie Sanders obviously
had a celebrity factor and bado and
Ocasio to some extent by the end got a
celebrity factor but is there an
institutional way that progressives can
organize so that candidates for Congress
who may not be very famous or get Oh ton
of media attention can still develop a
grassroots donor basis and be less
reliant on maxout contributions and I
think all of us need to work towards
doing it so don't take PAC money
and expand grassroots fundraising I
think our two intermediate steps so I
want to stick with sort of financial or
economic money related issues for a
little bit being a representative of
Silicon Valley you follow closely what
happens with some of these large
corporation
which provide very useful products and
services there's no doubt they create
jobs but also they do receive the lion's
share of some of the benefits of the
status quo system that we have so I want
to talk about the Amazon $15 minimum
wage a little bit I have my thoughts on
it and and I know you have an
interesting take on it what was your
reaction when you saw that Amazon was
raising its minimum wage company-wide to
$15 well I think it was important
response to senator Sanders and I
introducing the stop Bezos Act we
basically called on Jeff Bezos about a
month before he increased his minimum
wage to do so and we said it's
ridiculous that Amazon is a trillion
dollar company and that yet they're not
paying their workers enough and their
workers are actually relying on food
stamps and public benefits and taxpayers
are having to subsidize employees at the
richest company in the world and that
the worker conditions aren't up to
standard in some of the warehouses they
haven't allowed unionization and we
explicitly said to send it to Jeff Bezos
be the Henry Ford of your time raise
wages in direct response to that Bezos
said I've heard my critics in the end in
fact tag senator Sanders and he said
that he was going to raise wages to $15
in some times it was a vindication for
senator Sanders and I because we were
attacked mercilessly by the Beltway for
going after Jeff Bezos now it's not
perfect the Jeff Bezos took away stock
options from workers who were not
minimum wage workers but middle-income
workers and he's taken away some of the
bonuses as I understand it 350,000
Amazon employees are still going to get
a pay raise and net they're better off I
wish he didn't take away those bonuses
but I still think it was a step in the
right direction and to some degree I
mean there's no doubt that it's the
right decision at the same time we all
know it's calculated and that there's a
PR benefit that also has a financial
value sort sort of attached to it and I
think it can be sometimes true
for progressives in these situations you
don't want to be seen as pooh-poohing
anything that these corporations do when
they do the right thing at the same time
it's a it's important and sometimes
difficult I I would argue to couch it in
a context where this is sort of like
safe activism right whether they pay 12
15 or 18 dollars the status quo in which
they can circumvent the tax law to avoid
paying taxes legally and all of this
other stuff it doesn't change that and I
think it does make it so that
progressives have to think carefully
about how to react to decisions like
this I agree I mean the it doesn't
change the fact that they may not be
supportive of unionization it doesn't
change the fact that they're paid zero
percent corporate tax in 2017 it doesn't
change the fact that we have to be
vigilant to make sure they don't acquire
a monopoly power in different industries
at the same time we do have to in my
view acknowledge when companies try to
take a step in the right direction so
that there are other companies like
Walmart or McDonald's who feel the same
incentive so that's also a job for
people like you I mean politicians that
we're gonna is celebrate if there's a
concrete outcome of success but I think
you have to hold not just the
politicians accountable but also
corporations accountable to say okay
it's a step in the right direction but
we still need a far more structural
change can you talk a little bit right
now about who you think can most
effectively hold corporations
accountable and to cut to contextualise
the question trial lawyers are very
divisive and controversial on the one
hand you hear a lot of critics of trial
lawyers including friends of ours down
at Levin Papantonio in Pensacola Florida
Mike Papantonio hosts a ring of fire and
others who are doing really really great
work you hear criticisms about so-called
trial lawyers that they get 30% of all
the settlement money that should go to
individuals and all sorts of critiques
of self-enrichment but at the same time
these corporations have such financial
resources it can take millions of
dollars to even get somebody like DuPont
to trial who other than these
well-resourced law firms can actually do
it so I'd love to hear from you a little
bit about what are the institutions that
can actually hold corporations
accountable in a real Dweck real way I
think the United States Congress can is
Bernie Sanders showed we by telling
people's stories and using the bully
pulpit of Congress effectively you can
really embarrass corporations into
thinking that there's a PR cost for them
if they are not treating their workers
well the other folks who can hold
corporations accountable are the workers
themselves it takes great courage for
workers at these companies to come
forward and tell their stories but when
they do when they organize and when they
share those stories and when you have
journalists like yourself amplify those
stories on social media I think that
puts tremendous pressure on corporations
so we shouldn't underestimate the role
of the bully pulpit in getting
corporations to do the right thing we
also need to relook at the rules though
of our free market system rules that
right now have benefitted stockholders
and those receiving dividends over
workers and we need to rewrite some of
those rules to make sure that you don't
have stock buybacks to make sure that
you do have workers represented on the
boards of these companies to make sure
that you have environments that permit a
unionization and those are things that
Elizabeth Warren Bernie Sanders or brown
have talked about and that if we have a
majority in Congress we should try to
pass in part two I definitely want to
touch on what would be the number what
would be the immediate to dues if indeed
the Democrats take over the house very
very soon in the midterm elections but
before we get to that what you mentioned
independent media a couple of times I am
curious I mean how much do folks in
Congress know about this sort of growing
tide of independent media outlets these
sort of alternatives to corporate media
that increasingly have larger and larger
audiences sometimes it can feel from our
end like we're sort of just
walking here and we don't know whether
those who are actually in positions of
power know about independent media is
this I mean how do you characterize that
or people they're aware of what we're
doing
the savvy ones are you know who was
aware of independent media is Donald
Trump he spent hours and hours giving
interviews not just to cable news but to
the right-wing alternative media going
on radio stations and radio programs
going and talking to internet bloggers
and he was very savvy about that
I think progressive politicians need to
realize that going on CNN and MSNBC and
having an article in The New York Times
is not sufficient that many people
listen to alternate media and that it's
a huge strategic advantage to get your
message out and I do think people like
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and
some others have realized that and
that's to their advantage so I think
many people listen to you and those
politicians who don't take it seriously
are hurting their own strategic
interests of how to get a message out we
have been speaking with congressman roe
Khanna who represents California 17th
congressional district located in
Silicon Valley San Francisco Bay Area we
will pause our conversation with him
there and continue tomorrow we are
continuing our conversation with
congressman row Khanna who represents
California's 17th congressional district
to pick up our conversation congressman
you have taken a very I believe
principled approach when it comes to the
issue of our relationship with Saudi
Arabia and this relates to Yemen this
relates to the recent death of
journalist Jamal khashoggi this relates
to the arms deals what can be done
because it does seem to some degree like
an exercise in futility this
relationship that is in great part based
on sort of a shared interest in Middle
East stability concerns around oil
concerns around arms deals I mean is is
this thing too big to really interrupt
I don't think so even in my time in
Congress I've noticed a shift in public
opinion in an opinion on the hill I
started sounding the alarm about gammon
three months into my term and
Congress I was concerned about the
humanitarian crisis there and more I was
concerned that we don't get suckered
into another war in the Middle East the
neoconservatives wanted us to support
the Southey's efforts in Yemen as a
counter to Iran and as a check on Iran
they have been clamoring for us to get
into a conflict with Iran and I thought
that that would be a disaster since that
time when I introduced the War Powers
Resolution to stop our aid for the
Saudis there has been growing consensus
that this war must stop a part of it is
14 million people 12 to 14 million
Yemenis faced possible famine I mean
that's incomprehensible 800,000 people
died in Rwanda and here you're looking
at a scale of famine that is just
mind-blowing
and that has finally I think a post
Khashoggi awaken the conscience of many
members of Congress they realized that
Khashoggi was actually writing about the
Yemen war that's one of the reasons he
was murdered so now we have a growing
number of people in Congress who
recognize that the war must stop even
sexy mattes yesterday talked about the
war in Yemen stopping there a growing
number of folks who are questioning the
Saudi relationship
we just need continued citizen
mobilization we need to continue to
fight for this but I think this is a
issue that we can win and we must win
given the number of lives at stake how
concerned are you about this sort of
being enamored or impressed by
authoritarian types by the current
president right now and this applies to
Rodrigo Duterte dis applies to Kim
jong-un this applies to Bashar al-assad
it certainly applies to the Saudi royal
family is that a media only story or
does that have real-world diplomatic
impact no I am concerned that this
president hasn't spoken out clearly on
human rights and seems to be indifferent
to human suffering or human rights when
he deals with
dictators abroad his instincts as a
candidate to have less intervention
overseas I thought were promising in his
sense that we wanted to reset the
us-russia relationship to avoid another
Cold War that we shouldn't be
intervening in Syria that we should pull
our troops out of Afghanistan all of
that I thought was a necessary course
correction from a neoconservative
foreign policy but having restraint in
foreign policy doesn't mean that we
ignore human rights abuses we can
believe that we shouldn't be intervening
militarily in Syria but still believe
that Assad is a brutal terrible dictator
and speak out against his human rights
abuses that call for International
Criminal Court of Justice to deal with
war crimes we can believe that we
shouldn't be intervening in the Middle
East but still recognize the human
rights abuses of the Saudis and when it
comes to human rights this president has
had a blind spot that is not consistent
with American values I tend to look to
John Quincy Adams who said we shouldn't
be intervening abroad but we should
always have our prayers or hopes or
moral expressions on the side of those
who stand for freedom and human rights
so if Democrats do take over the house
in November ultimately in in January
they would be sworn in but not the
Senate what are the priorities do they
relate to geopolitics and foreign policy
is it domestic policy is it economic
versus social and obviously that you
have to kind of balance that with the
pragmatism of what can you do at this
point in all likelihood without a
Democratic Senate what are your top
priorities well I think they're
connected we should stop the wars
overseas and the trillions of dollars
we've spent overseas and put that money
into developing our own nation our own
education our own infrastructure the
Republicans have been for war overseas
and for tax cuts for billionaires for
giving people like Sheldon Adelson a 670
million dollar tax break the Democrats
should say we don't want that money
going into conflicts we can't win or to
the billionaire class we want that money
going in to build rebuild communities to
create jobs
community colleges to provide internet
for everyone to provide healthcare for
everyone through medicare for all to
fight for a $15 minimum wage to build
our infrastructure that what is urgent
for America in the 21st century is to
rebuild communities and to rebuild this
country so that everyone has an economic
shot so I think that the two are
actually linked in terms of foreign
policy and economic policy when you talk
about foreign policy abstractly and say
Saudi Arabia Yemen Iran people may glaze
over but when you put it in terms that
trillions of dollars are going overseas
and conflicts we can't win and that
money should be helping their kids have
a better economic future I think people
get it when it comes to some of the
specific elections I got a bunch of
questions from people in the audience
that they wanted me to ask her one is
you ultimately supported Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes in New York but after
initially supporting Joe Crowley some
folks want to know what made you
initially support Crowley well you know
I was part of the Congress and Crowley
had come out for medicare-for-all
and he we had he had invited me to visit
his district in Queens and there was
this brilliant program in Queens that
was helping minority community
population get tech jobs and I got
connected with him and so I knew Joe
Crowley and that's why I supported him
but once I got became more aware of
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes and the
inspiring campaign she was running I
endorsed her and dual endorsed I was the
only member of Congress to do that there
it was at some political risk in
retrospect I wish I had done that right
away but I'm glad that I made that
course correction and I think she's
going to be an exceptional candidate I
also think candidly I got a lot of
feedback on social media about
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes that helped me
be ahead of the curve and see the
extraordinary campaign she was running
and so that's another point that people
do listen to independent media and
social media in making these decisions
if
crowds do win back the house will you
support Nancy Pelosi as Speaker a bunch
of people asked about this here's why I
do two reasons one there's no
progressive alternative
I don't want Steny Hoyer to become
Speaker of the House and if you don't
support Nancy most likely the
speakership moves to the right so for
those of folks who want to replace Nancy
Pelosi with a progressive alternative I
say okay who's the progressive candidate
who has the votes to be able to beat her
or to be able to beat Steny Hoyer a
second I think having so many
accomplished women run and win and
having the first woman Speaker I think
giving me an C the gavel and then having
a transition to a more progressive
speakership is what makes the most sense
and it may give us time with all these
new progressives like Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes and Rashida to leave for the
progressive caucus to organize to groom
someone who's a successor I think we
would lose an election right now to
Steny Hoyer or someone else if we didn't
have Nancy so do I think what I do think
is we should hold Nancy to commit to
supporting a boat on Medicare for all to
supporting a vote for a $15 minimum wage
to supporting an end to the war in Yemen
and try to get as many of our
progressive policies be a priority would
would your vote for her be conditional
on her agreeing to get a vote on those
issues I wouldn't put it as conditional
when I have talked with mark Pocan and
famila is that the Progressive Caucus
should make it clear what our priorities
are and have a meeting with Nancy to try
to to get that commitment and you know I
don't believe people respond well to
sort of threats and conditional
statements but I think we should be very
clear where we stand and where the
energy of the party is and I also think
we should be at the same time focused on
grooming someone whether it's marked or
Pramila or someone in the Progressive
Caucus who could run to be the next
speaker I'll tell you one person one
supporting is barbara Lee for the house
caucus chair now Barbara if she wins
that race you know she may be a terrific
a successor to Nancy so we need to be
pragmatic in making sure that when we
move after Nancy we get a progressive
leader and not someone who moves the
caucus to the right last thing I want to
talk about it I know you just have a few
more minutes to spend with us and it
relates to exactly this conversation
we're having which is that of pragmatism
versus idealism and I talked to a lot of
people in my audience who get angry with
me when I point out that there are some
races where you give away a seat to
Republicans by going after the centrist
Democrat that is there however I fully
support the primary of illiberal
Democrats or Democrats that are failing
to really be progressive and there are
many of them in the house and as well in
the Senate can you explain your
philosophy for finding that balance
between wanting to move to the left and
realistically quickly as quickly as
possible with not doing self-inflicted
damage well first I think our party
needs to adopt bold progressive
proposals we should be as a democratic
party for Medicare for all we should be
for a $15 minimum wage we should be for
abolishing impact money not taking PAC
money as candidates or at the DNC we
should be for a trillion dollar
infrastructure package we should be for
net neutrality and we should have
progressive standard bearers like Bernie
Sanders leading the party and
progressives in leadership then I say
okay once the Democrats stand is a
progressive party then we should
understand that not everyone in their
particular districts is going to agree
with all of the progressive platform and
if there's someone running in a more
conservative district and they want to
depart from the Democratic philosophy
they should be able to do that and we
need to recognize that it's going to
take all types of people to build a
governing majority the problem I have
now is we don't have a coherent
democratic progressive platform we have
a lowest common denominator everyone run
whatever the way they want for their
districts that's not how the
Conservatives do it the Conservatives
have a concern
platform and then they let the Susan
Collins or others in some discrete
issues break from the party I think that
would be a model the Democrat should
have a clear progressive standard-bearer
and platform but having some flexibility
for people in their own districts to
tailor that so that we can have a
governing majority yeah you know that's
I I've gotten a lot of heat for saying
something similar and people wrote to me
and said David isn't that a bit of a
double standard because on the one hand
you're praising the fact that
Republicans seem not to have a litmus
test and allow people like Susan Collins
to be there but at the same time you're
sort of saying that we need real
progressives and instituting some sort
of de facto litmus test on the Left how
do we balance that because we don't want
to be hypocrites on it but I completely
agree with the conclusion that you're
coming to well I think the there is not
a litmus test in my view for every
district but there may be certain
principles that we say we want our
standard bearers to have so I believe in
Medicare for all I would find it a very
very hard to imagine any case where I
would support a presidential candidate
that doesn't believe in a robust version
of Medicare for all but if there is a
district in one some part of the country
where a candidate is not running on
Medicare for all but it's gonna be a
Republican so we can have the house of
majority I still may go out and campaign
for them let me give you an example
Chris Pappas hasn't come out for
Medicare for all in New Hampshire I
supported a progressive alternative for
him in the primary but now that he's the
nominee I want to make sure he wins but
I don't want Chris Pappas being my
presidential nominee so I think there
has to be a clear set of priorities that
our leaders embrace but there has to be
some flexibility district-by-district
to build a governing majority that's at
least my perspective i I know different
people have different views on this but
it's a it's a tough question we've been
speaking with congressman roe Khanna who
represents California 17th congressional
district located in Silicon Valley
includes the San Francisco Bay Area
congressman really a pleasure having you
on thank you Dave great to be on
let's do it again and I will continue to
follow your show